today's video is kindly supported by
rise of kingdoms
hey 42 here on the evening of january
the 16th
1920 the streets of new york witnessed a
funeral
unlike any other crowds of people
descended upon restaurants
hotels cafes and bars to pay their
respects and share their sorrows
rooms across the city were decorated
with black tablecloths
and painted walls orchestras played
funeral marches set to jazz time
and weeping mourners raised their
glasses one last time
to toast the departed the following
morning
the new york times published a eulogy
with the resonating headline
john barleycorn died peacefully at the
tall of 12.
the fact that his death provoked such a
grand response
was rather odd given that he never
actually existed
in the flesh rise of kingdoms is a
multi-civilization
mobile strategy game that combines
real-time strategy gameplay
after launching almost three years ago
now it has over 60 million players
worldwide
within rise of kingdoms you have the
option to choose between
any of 12 civilizations that have
actually appeared throughout history
like a traditional strategy game you're
able to collect resources
in order to build your own city upgrade
your buildings
train your soldiers cultivate your
commanders
and research technology to improve your
combat power
and you are able to choose the viking
civilization
now with their legendary leaders ragnar
lothbrok
and bjorn ironside you will lead the
viking warriors
all the way from the loire river in a
bid to conquer the world
one of the best things about the game is
the scale of the map with over 1.44
million digital square meters
it will take some exploring and i love
that the game has real mornings and
evenings
as well as real terrain rise of kingdoms
is free to download and free to play
click on the link in the description box
below to download the game
now use code rok vikings in
game best of all you also have the
chance to win an
iphone 12 pro max iphone 12
pro or iphone 12 and a lot of in-game
resources
all you need to do is click on the
second link in the description
you see john barleycorn was more of a
symbol
his character taken from a pagan folk
song
was meant to be the personification of
whiskey and
beer and his demise had been a long time
coming
exactly a year before this fictitious
funeral took place
the 18th amendment was ratified
prohibiting
the manufacture sale or transportation
of intoxicating glickers anywhere within
the united states and although
president woodrow wilson tried to veto
it congress succeeded
in pushing through the volstead act
named after andrew volstead
a minnesota politician who champions the
new legislation
in between grooming his formidable
mustache
my god that's a mustache if ever i saw
one
anyway this change was met with funerals
of a very different kind
across america's bible belt one
particularly
raucous celebration took place in
virginia and was hosted by billy sunday
a professional baseball player turned
evangelical preacher
billy had never been a fan of the
so-called
john barleycorn to put it mildly in fact
he saw the volstead act
as a victory over satan himself to
really
drive his point home he hired someone to
dress up as satan
follow a group of pallbearers carrying a
coffin to the church
and sit down to watch the proceedings
with a face like a smacked ass
and to show his guests exactly what they
wouldn't be missing in the future
billy even hired people to pretend to be
completely
pissed and harass guests with
inarticulate insults
it's fair to say he really got into the
spirit of things
but questionable hosting skills aside
billy was far from alone in his
enthusiasm for the long
dry spell in fact the groundwork for
national abstinence
was laid down more than a century before
his
booze-free bash in the early 1800s
heavy drinking was the norm with the
average american man drinking up to 12
gallons of alcohol a year that's around
20 shots
each week considering the average annual
consumption
of the modern american is just 2.3
gallons
that's pretty impressive and so many
towns and cities resembled
a perpetual freshers week many were
disgusted by what they saw
and so a fierce sentiment against
alcohol
began to emerge across the nation
political figureheads started to point
the finger at alcohol for all of
society's ills
gout liver problems madness
violence promiscuity and pretty much
anything else considered a sin
people began to abstain from alcohol
voluntarily
and persuaded others to do the same
resulting in a widespread temperance
movement
the movement was especially popular
amongst women who orchestrated sit-ins
and protests in saloons and distilleries
some temperance groups managed to stop
alcohol sales altogether
in parts of the midwest and west and
even industrialist businessmen like
henry ford got on board
in the hope it would make his factories
safer and his workers more productive
as the temperance movement gained
momentum the anti-saloon league
emerged led by a man named wayne wheeler
wayne had always disliked alcohol ever
since a drunk farmhand
accidentally stabbed his foot with a
pitchfork when he was a child
from that point on he made it his life's
mission to put a stop to
drunken antics once and for all and
became the most successful political
lobbyist in america
it was said that he could hand-pick
senators
and make or break presidents he even
schmoozed with the kkk
who were in favor of the movement and
stirred tensions between
rural white americans and increasing
number of immigrants
bringing in whiskey beer and wine
he claims that these drinks were
weakening the nation's moral fiber
and that prohibition was synonymous with
patriotism
i always force it with eagles and guns
but perhaps i'm mistaken
the issue divided north america
religiously
socially and politically those who
supported prohibition
became known as the dries and were
mainly made up of protestant republicans
who lived in rural areas
whereas the wets tended to be democrats
city dwellers and catholic immigrants
on november the 11th 1918 the armistice
ending world war one was signed
and an intoxicating mixture of victory
and anti-immigrant sentiment
permeated the air the dries rode that
momentum
and a few weeks later the 18th amendment
became law and the penalties for
breaking that law
were substantial you could be fined up
to ten
thousand dollars a ridiculously large
sum back then
and sentenced to a full year in prison
because of this the police didn't
anticipate too much trouble in enforcing
it
but boy were they wrong like any law
there were loopholes and the wets
managed to exploit these leap holes
with admiral creativity the law
forbade the transport and purchase of
alcohol
but it was still permitted for medicinal
purposes
so it'll come as no surprise that 1920s
saw a sudden surge
in alcohol prescriptions eight million
gallons of the stuff to be precise
which is enough to fill 64 million pint
glasses
back then alcohol was used to cure
anything from cholera to cancer
so if you suddenly felt like you had a
disease or infection that only alcohol
could cure
you could just pop right along to your
local doctor get a prescription
and order your beverage of choice at the
pharmacy alcohol also began to take on
some
inconspicuous disguises you might find
it inside a watermelon
or an egg underneath a nun's habit
or tucked inside a pram which to be fair
you can still see on certain streets in
britain today there is even a fake
book not so subtly titled
spring poems the four swallows
which contained four glass vials
get it one of the most popular methods
was to hollow cane
which you can still buy today if you
want to be more of a gentlemanly
alcoholic
californian wineries sold dried raisin
cakes
which were labeled with a very helpful
warning to consumers that if you
fermented them
they just so happen to turn into
delicious
wine oh my what a coincidence
but the reward for the most elaborate
masquerade goes to those who dressed up
as priests
transformed their homes into churches
and had their mates around
for a casual congregation all in an
effort
to get hold of some sacramental wine
if you didn't fancy faking cholera
carving out an egg or staging a full
sermon with all the trimmings in your
kitchen
another option was to hunt down and gain
entry to
a speakeasy if you had the right
password that is
speakeasies were private unlicensed bar
rooms
and prohibitions worst kept secret
there were literally thousands of them
ranging from basement dives to
high-end ballrooms and they were hugely
popular
for the first time in america's history
men and women
were able to drink together in public
and the nations shimmied into the jazz
field
liquor infused party known as the
roaring twenties
it wasn't illegal to drink in
speakeasies
remember the law forbade the manufacture
distribution
and sale of alcohol but not the
consumption of it
the owners of said establishments
however were very much breaking the law
and premises were raided on a daily
basis
in the early days the tactics used to
avoid igniting the cells were
rudimentary at best owners would fight
back at the police with
anything they had to hand cooking
equipment cutlery
crockery one officer was even knocked
out cold with a rolling pin
thankfully others were happy to look the
other way
in return for a drink on the house but
as prohibition continued speakeasies
became a lucrative business
and with a little more cash to spend
owners began to create
bond villain-worthy contraptions
at the 21 club in new york for instance
they installed a camouflage door a false
wall to hide a secret wine cellar
and even a button behind the bar that if
pushed
would drop all the bottles down to the
cellar to crash open
and drain out how were the owners
getting hold of alcohol in the first
place
if the wineries and breweries were no
longer in business
well although the government had put a
stop to the manufacture and sale of
alcoholic beverages
they couldn't do anything about the
production of industrial alcohol
unless they also happened to ban
essentials like paint
cleaning products and gasoline but
they never expected those products to be
an issue
since 1906 industrial alcohol was
denatured with unpleasant chemicals
to prevent people from drinking it and
thus circumvent the higher tax
levied on regular consumer alcohol
imagine drinking lighter fluid
and you'll appreciate why up to now it
had proved incredibly effective
but desperate times call for desperate
measures
literally and so moonshiners grabs their
lab coats
flasks and bunsen burners redistilled
industrial alcohol
and created something that was more or
less drinkable
and if you feel like having a go
yourself
here's how to make a prohibition classic
bathtub gin and when i say have a go
what i actually mean is never try this
at home
and please don't sue me first take the
cheapest alcohol you can find
and pour it into a huge jar if you can
get your hands on some denatured alcohol
great but be warned that it might cause
a mild case
of death now for some flavor
for a no-nonsense gin a handful of
juniper berries will do
but if you're feeling a little fancy add
a sprinkling of orange or lemon peel
next fill it with water your jar should
be too large to fill from a sink
so for a truly authentic experience fill
it from the bathtub
cover the jar store it in a cool dark
place
for a few days pasta gin for a strainer
and finally add the strongest mixer
available
to disguise the unbearable flavor
this kind of drink was often made at
home late at night
hence the term moonshine but it also
took on
a much larger scale bigger stills could
produce 5 gallons of alcohol in only 8
minutes
with commercial albeit underground
stills
pumping out 50 to 100 gallons a day
the bootleggers would sell it on to
speakeasies for a tidy profit
and the result of all this madness
a rapid surge in organized crime
as gangsters fought to control the
lucrative moonshine trade
of all the bootleggers who made it big
during the prohibition
the most infamous by far was al capone
who supplied huge quantities of alcohol
and ran gambling prostitution and other
rackets
in chicago throughout the twenties he
used bribery and intimidation to control
city officials
put gunmen on the roofs of polling
stations to make sure his favorite
politicians were elected
and orchestrated the saint valentine's
day massacre
where he ordered the murder of seven of
his rivals
so to say that the plans to create a
more pious nation
had backfired would be an understatement
in addition to organized crime people
were accepting
bribes left right and center and the
number of drinking establishments
had more than doubled since prohibition
began
the government had greatly
underestimated people's sheer
determination
to get utterly trollied they needed a
better plan
and fast before the country further
descended
into anarchy but nobody could have
foreseen
the lengths they would go to in order to
achieve it
on christmas eve 1926 a man
stumbled into a new york hospital
emergency room
flushed and trembling with fear santa
claus he told
the nurses was just behind him equipped
with a baseball bat
before anyone realized how sick he was
he died followed by another 64
deaths by the end of christmas day
doctors found that all 65 deaths
had been caused by highly toxic
additives
in industrial alcohol additives
that had been authorized by the federal
government
in a drastic attempt to limit the supply
of alcohol at its source
the government had underhandedly
authorized
poisonous methanol also known as wood
alcohol
to be added to any products that
contained
industrial alcohol methanol is extremely
dangerous because when your body digests
it
it breaks down into some uniquely
poisonous compounds
which cause dementia and ultimately
death
this resulted in an ongoing showdown
between the federal chemists
who were trying to make industrial
alcohol deadlier to drink
and the bootleggers chemists who had
found that they could
evaporate most of the poison by boiling
it
and for a while it seemed as though the
bootleggers were winning
the government attempted formula after
formula
but the rogue chemists continued to
renature it
by 1926 750
new york citizens had died from
government authorized poisons
and many had suffered from irreversible
injuries
such as paralysis and blindness
yes people were literally becoming blind
drunk
then on the 1st of january 1927
congress announced new legislation
requiring
double the amount of methanol to be
added to industrial alcohol products
which proved impossible to completely
filter out
the result was catastrophic one
government report
claimed that a 480
000 gallons of liquor confiscated in new
york in 1927
nearly all contained poison the
bootleggers
as expected had continued to sell the
treated alcohol
and it's estimated that more than 10 000
people across the states died as a
result
and whilst we're pretty sure today that
the government did take these steps to
prevent people
from breaking the law it raises some
awkward questions about the human
sacrifices
they were willing to make for those
gains
did they authorize the addition of
poisons knowing that people would sell
and
drink the alcohol anyway the facts
suggest that
at least some of them did the assistant
secretary of the treasury
seymour lowman openly told citizens that
drinkers were
dying off fast from poison hooch but if
it meant a sober america
it was a job well done as far as some
were concerned
and wayne wheeler remember him leader of
the anti-saloon league
evil mastermind unfortunate incident
with a pitchfork
yeah now you got it well he justified it
by claiming that anyone who drank
industrial alcohol
was committing suicide and that rooting
out a bad habit
costs lives whether the government
deliberately intended to poison american
citizens or not
they had already lost their trust partly
due to their own hypocrisies throughout
prohibition
president warren harding who had
campaigned as a dry
was known for throwing huge gatsby-esque
parties that were famous throughout
washington
and even in the capitol building there
was a secret
bar hidden within a curtain which was
supplied
by yep you guessed it confiscated
alcohol prohibition officially ended
with the ratification of the 21st
amendment
in 1933 but by that point
it was really just a formality whilst
organized crime had flourished tax
revenues
had depleted and as the 30s ushered in
the great depression
the government realized that they needed
the tax money from alcohol sales
more than they wanted sobriety but many
of prohibitions legacies live on today
classic cocktails such as the old
fashioned the bee's knees
and sidecar all made their debut during
prohibition
in an attempt to disguise the
foul-tasting glicker
and you can still find modern
speakeasies around the world
which attempt to recreate that alluring
feeling of going underground
and crossing the line of the law these
days police are less likely to turn up
but just in case they do it's always
worth taking a rolling pin
for good measure thanks for watching
thanks again to rise of kingdoms for
supporting this video
are you ready to build your kingdom
using 12 historically accurate
civilizations
then go ahead and click the link in the
description
and use code rok vikings to play today
and don't forget to click the second
link in the description
to enter the contest to win an iphone 12
pro max iphone 12 pro or iphone 12
and lots of in-game resources check it
out